the Mesoamerican quiz time Aztec or
Mayan Aztec or Mayan Aztec or Mayan one
more Aztec or Mayan believe it or not
these are two totally different
languages well almost
there are fundamental differences but
there's also one of history's strangest
linguistic mind-melds happening here so
often I find Aztecs and Mayans mentioned
in the same breath or the same
keystrokes so I can almost forgive you
for not knowing the difference between
the languages almost but after we're
done here no excuses okay first we're
not dealing with two languages here
hardly see Aztec which usually goes by
the name now what clear or I guess clear
speech is just one branch at the
southern edge of a much larger family
tree the Udo Aztec in language family
stretches from Idaho in the US all the
way down to El Salvador classical
nahuatl is the language spoken by the
people you're probably thinking of when
I say Aztecs but the modern now one
branch actually includes a whole cluster
closely related languages and dialects
Mayan is another story actually lots of
stories because it's an entire language
family each one of these is a Mayan
language but just to keep you on your
toes speakers of some of these
individual languages call their own
language Maya even when we don't -
linguists this is Yucatec but it's
really my Athan this one here John tal
is just the Nahuatl word john talley
meaning foreigner what are they
themselves call it though well usually
yogathon
correct language but also mayan to spot
some differences between Aztec and Mayan
compare basic words my last video is all
about the tactical use of the languages
in the Spanish conquest or this Aguila
and the star of the show Moline scene
used Nahuatl entrant al to turn an
empire against itself I'll be pulling
examples from these same two languages
to show off Aztec vs. Mayan just a heads
up though I have a little more
experience with youdo Aztec in than Maya
I once got into another rather different
euro as second language and I've spent
more time with classical nahuatl than
anyone Mayan language hopefully that
explains any glitches in pronunciation
let me start by hand picking things that
stand out about their sounds now what'll
is known for that distinctive and for
this Sal Theo skip or glottal stop
that's often between a vowel and a
consonant it's awkward at first but try
playing and skipping to get a feel for
it for yourself
Nashik got a lot de l'année besides a
couple affricates and a difference
between a regular and a hole made by
rounding your lips nothing else is too
scary in the pronunciation Department
now what lonely has for vowels no
but it does distinguish short ones from
long ones ah ah II II also there's this
relentless second last syllable stress
bum BA bum bum de no it's deep lime
local tan on the other hand has six
vowels and it's consonants include the
ever so Mayan ejective stops that build
up and release air pressure call them
exotic call them aggressive personally I
like them but they're on full display in
this Mayan language so let me try this
Cheech versus Cheech both and both basic
nouns in Maya are a simple affair often
just one syllable so now it's like true
and not are ready to use no fanciness no
plural endings of course this makes
compounding super common not necessarily
longest word in the world kind of
compounding but still not nouns that
refer to people are often prefixed with
aa male or ish female even when that's
not information you're used to including
in English each guy a chi yogathon
yogathon aa Jame what about Nahuatl
nouns well I hope you've been practicing
your two because you're gonna need it on
their own
now it'll nouns have a base plus an
ending like mushy cut depending on the
last letter in the route the noun suffix
might take another shape which is why
house is golly not valid if the noun is
alive it has an animate plural so one
may she got many mashita inanimate Cali
stays Cali your house isn't alive is it
now comes the fun part
now it'll nouns love to be possessed by
possessive prefixes knock off the ending
attach a pronoun prefix and the party's
at no con my house or Moka your house
but definitely not at no Connelly
similar pronoun bits are very valuable
in yogathon but not in a way that's so
bound up with every now and it makes it
change its shape not I'm not
well not it's possible to think of as
taking my incor words like nouns and
verbs as sentence builders in their own
right check out what happens when you
build a sentence using just a noun and
adding the subject marker to it like
going from not and una - una it in Maya
or may she cut and D may she cut in
Aztec I spent some time with nouns and
possessives because this is an inkling
of a similarity worth keeping in mind
we'll build on it later when it comes to
verbs both languages care about
transitivity in now what will you take a
verb like wetsy Makkah or qua and tack
on a subject these are the same subjects
we use to build sentences out of nouns
Dima she cut D wet C D maka you can then
add in your object nee makka makka makka
niqua niqua or even little aqua with
that fancy unknown object I think
transitivity is an even bigger player in
mine beyond just the shape of the verb
in some tenses aspects Maya displays
something called purgative 'ti the short
story is this if a Mayan verb is
intransitive then it's subject looks
like an object take a transitive verb a
cushy where you are the subject and
you're still the subject in the
intransitive verb we get even though you
look different
this sets Mayan apart from both English
and now up since we use the same
subjects for transitive and intransitive
verbs I am the same and I eat it niqua
and in I fall me witzy accusative
languages vs. argot of languages that
probably just made your eyes glaze over
let me resuscitate you with something
easier prepositions you know these guys
you got him in English shown thousands
got him too and it uses them for
location and relation so if you remember
that King was money we can
just say dr. King for with money that's
not how Nahuatl works though it uses
post fixes for these kinds of time and
place relationships like the one for
togetherness is one mole one with you or
location go Galco in the house these go
beyond our prepositions though switch
off your indo-european mind and think
internationally for this one take a
little word that seems atomic
unbreakable even like and yeah now it'll
and is a multi-part construction built
using a postfix II one its togetherness
or with it okay you are officially a
linguistic warrior for sticking with me
that was just a random grammar sampling
but you now have a gist of the
differences between these languages time
for the payoff with your refined
grammatical palate let's rewind and play
the game again Aztec or Mayan Aztec or
Mayan Aztec or Mayan haha there we go
but if you couldn't tell them apart
before I don't think it was just sheer
ignorance
you probably had hazy ideas of
similarities and no real understanding
of the differences but there was
something to those similarities
something deep when you characterize a
language you probably go straight for
what we call the genetic relationship
what kind of language is Spanish why
it's a Romance language what about
classical nahuatl you know Aztec and of
course john talley Akutan that's mayan
all true and we can go around breaking
up pre-columbian Mesoamerican into this
patchwork of distinct color coded
language families if we stop there
though we'll miss out on the best part
of the story there's another factor that
majorly influences languages in an
almost bizarrely stealthy kind of way
when languages even totally and utterly
unrelated ones lives side by side for a
long time they start to exchange stuff
not just can I bar the sugar can I have
your chocolate and chiles kind of stuff
I'm sure a Mayan language might borrow
Aztec words just as people all over the
region were sharing goods and ideas but
that didn't leave a huge dent
instead of surface stuff like words and
sounds the languages of Mesoamerica
started to trade
structure I don't want your nouns I want
the way your nouns and pronouns work to
influence my nouns and pronouns
linguists call this phenomenon a shock
point a language area as taken mind
participated in one of history's
greatest the Mesoamerican language area
show-and-tell time what kinds of
linguistic mind-melds were happening
here first a simple one word order
Mesoamerica likes to keep verbs away
from the end of a sentence verb subject
object is very Mayan and even though
classical now it was pretty free and how
let you order words it tended to like
verb subject object or even verb object
subject the languages that surround
Mesoamerica though they totally disagree
they had no problem with a verb final
syntax with subject object verb being
very very common and those possessives
they come back full force with kind of
awkward Mesoamerican way of saying that
somebody owns something it's like this
her house the woman their bones the dogs
in Aztec I think you'd say II Colleen
see what you know mewing chichi me but
it works the same way all over of course
that core words build sentences concept
from earlier comes back here so have fun
with examples like Eagle II masuo back
to Mesoamerican postpositions and
prepositions those time-space references
love to include body parts so instead of
saying inside why not say it big its
stomach for around use a thank ou on its
lips or try Maya pum head for in front
like pummel tote and head of house for
in front of the house
they even count the same way not with
your decimal system their system is
based 20 Aztecs simple wali 20 is
literally just one count units like
eighty are easy just counted scores not
bow Ali 4 counts as a consequence your
major Mesoamerican milestones weren't
hundreds or thousands but things like 20
squared and 20 cubits for these like the
old Mayan buck or now it'll since only
all of these and more are features of
Mesoamerica some are even rare outside
of it even in the very same language
families the way to explain them is to
look at how the
languages converged around the very same
traits I find this fascinating in a way
it's like you can proudly keep the look
and feel of your language but behind the
scenes we'll all agree to work
differently similarly not differently
huh well thanks for making it through
this grammar class I know it's a bit of
a switch but I hope it helps you
appreciate the story from last time or
you know the next time you study a
modern Mayan language modern Mayan
language wait did the mine's like
disappear something yeah and I think
that happened when the world ended back
in December 2012
heck no they didn't but that's a story
for another time stick around and
subscribe for language
you